hello hello hello yo yo what what what's
up everybody happy Tuesdays Persia here
and Lily's back hello to play some games
yeah and I'm excited today we're playing
sea of solitude which just came out this
past Friday and it's a really pretty
game I saw the launch trailer I thought
it was really interesting and it's kind
of like you know emo teenage me would
have been all over this team no no I
mean I'm cool with it I'm still in that
emo teenager
I'm excited also I just loved the title
and also the fact that it looks like
you're probably gonna be eaten by a
monster and I'm not stoked yeah exactly
and you know this is gonna be fresh to
us both I mean I've you know seen some
videos and watch the trailer but you
know I wanted to save the fresh eyes and
fresh opinions for you guys for the
stream today so let's turn it up game
volume a little bit all right let's get
this started and what's up everyone
welcome welcome back crime PWRs whoa
that was already super creepy and like
we didn't even start what was that
interesting already oh hi hi yeah I kind
of that was kind of scary there we go
new brand new game sea of Solitude
this game contains sensitive topics that
some players might find distressing
related to mental and emotional wellness
this was actually why I was really
interested in like playing this game
because you know it's kind of a book
about this girl and she's very lonely
and I think something along this story
is like when you become too lonely you
turn into a monster or something like
that
damn so yeah it's pretty deep it's
pretty crazy but I'm into trying to
piece it together hello Patrick what's
up me lord hi iconic you too are you
quite easy to talk about them yeah k is
her name oh this is already like I have
friends heartwrenching I think it's here
I am feeling lonely again hey if you
like that sometimes what is wrong with
me
I'm so tired of it damn tired
it must be a way out of here I want to
change it
James me whoo all right
this is already deep this is already
deep but hello everyone welcome we're
playing sea of Solitude we're currently
playing on the ps4 but think it's also
available on other platforms as well
she's still gonna cute for being a
quote-unquote monster why is it so dark
all right
maybe what's wrong all right let's do
this they might need help yes I should
get closer
alright gotta make it through this this
oceans terrifying looking ocean there's
something generally just scary about
being in the middle of the ocean no
matter where you are in my opinion
look like looks like a person
it does
hey are you alright okay you here again
do you know who I am
what a silly question here I have a
present for you be safe questions NRI I
literally do not know and then she flies
away oh yeah I haven't seen a sudden
John implies being alone make you
monster I must be terrifying that's
better
oh she's back
very whimsical
[Music]
Wow how did she
[Music]
huh I must be imagining this but see
like no they're really gonna be done and
she won't help us at all
you know you can't use it to go on shoot
it great she gave us a weapon a weapon
where she gave us power a fire flare and
she's a lefty exactly I love how K's on
our wavelength we're like who who are
you where are we going
yeah Briggs I'm enjoying the art style
so far to my students it's very like
imagine miss it like it's a world that
seems familiar but it's not what we
being these stick boat tricks who drift
oh I'm sorry
you can fly I know right I can boat I
can sail you still haven't given us any
answers and why do I have the endurance
you it's all right Kay is having fun
it's all that matters that was that
no-look pass
[Music]
[Music]
seed that's why you don't go around and
after being here like that for stories I
think I should have put the cherry no
idea what you're doing do you sure did
you do something to the girl yes yes oh
my goodness oh my goodness yeah it's
like I don't even want to be next to her
she's like girl making me feel horrible
about myself I don't like this yeah word
and unboard
give me the line yeah same right that's
how I view feeling sometimes will be a
dream right fire the hole just spend it
in your backpack
I need that backpacks I can clear a
corruption in my day to day to day life
[Laughter]
[Music]
hold it yeah
this sounds painful mekin even your
mouth okay she's distracted good we
deserve it we need to find more light
sweet all right so we gotta find more
light easy peasy
morbo does life
maybe she's still alive oh she's
creeping now that's scary oh it's okay
breathe breathe this isn't gonna just
see you here time no thanks yeah my
thoughts exactly
I'll look somewhere else there's a
bottle over there word
no just for peace of mind so big bad
wolf basically we met a friend and then
she went to go try to protect us and I
think she's gotten eaten alive or
something so we're credible we're trying
to find her now so we have this monster
keeps talking all this trash and
belittling us and then we have our
friend that we have to find that you
know we don't know her name
and she's laughing at us there's no door
she put her hand on it though that was
nothing
like she acknowledges that it's a door a
little girl girl girl hey girl
well it's sleep the Flair went that way
yeah I feel like it automatically goes
to where you need it where you're like
it wants you to go
oh girl I know that just focuses on
monster are there snares the low girl
jump on the monster Thursday oh oh
that's the next level thinking alright
let's do it then you know where's our
boat maybe we could take the boat around
yeah can you swim can I like go now go
now go now so yes so fast
what's the seagull doing Oh gonna reveal
oh wait one of 32 we've set him free Oh
guess no one wants to be around us
apparently not the seagulls not the girl
okay I can
yeah wait until furry hardened Bo not
gonna
[Laughter]
it's like kind of sad that if they do
turn into monsters to their loans like
he must have been so lonely
oh yeah cuz it has a light oh yeah I
think that's all you needed to say okay
so we got to find the other buoys I
think uh-oh do you have to pull the
monster over towards it and then light
it Oh a ladder this is a good sign okay
just for a better swim oh wait I think I
can get on I think it's buoy maybe as a
you know to get over to it yeah check
your left
and go clear the corruption
then that backpack is amazing Bob all
right now whoa there's a bus down there
it's beautifully yeah
two buses except the other ones I'm
gonna get to go where the darkness is Oh
walk towards my seat then I worry about
furry fish Oh peacefully it's like
walking on the beach
okay hey girl oh this windows open now
hello you leavin a mess I don't think
it's don't mind if you rest here like I
did and even go into the living room
dang okay what kind of Airbnb is this
all right where did all this water come
from and what happened to the people it
sounds like something girl knows but we
can't find her and she probably wouldn't
tell us know
she'll say you don't know okay so we
third the area that's cool but that
guy's still there
lady right and your boat is still on the
other side I don't know if you're gonna
need it again wait we came in from this
part yeah yeah I'm so nice to maybe
there's something over here right all
right cool oh crap oh it's dark again I
want to go back into the light so much
oh okay let's do this
I found the light that area is clear
cool air B & C alright sunny day
[Music]
basketball man I want a good distance
where the boat yeah where's the boat
give us our boat back wait maybe I can't
go back this boat for us okay well we
didn't go in okay we well we should
probably go do feel like that way yeah
that's the monster I waited five what a
Bob Jones welcome back to the stream
hello
Ilan we are playing sea of Solitude
right now currently on ps4 if I thought
so available I believe on Xbox one and
PC came out this past Friday and I think
it's really cool it's a cool concept
they kind of shed some light
some might say on mental awareness and
stuff like that through video games
which i think is amazing I kinda miss
boat yeah I missed the boat alright so
this whole area seems to be can I go
through here I think I have to find a
way to unlock it can you throw the fire
fire while you're swimming no but you
wouldn't good idea oh that's yeah I
don't want to be in the water when it
goes dark oh well the flare wants me to
go that way but I'm like oh the water's
rising
Oh dive dive dive
okay well that air is corrupted
oh-oh-oh-oh
that was new hello monster monsters tail
so you're staying as far away as
possible close to the wall yeah close
the wall so stay okay so back here let's
do this okay going through the house
bumping her and going up here yeah Wow
look at this nice beautiful home and
it's rooftop kids can Airbnb is getting
a little bit more feeling yeah air beans
maybe and I'm over here just okay cool I
have to go higher I remember correctly
the light is up here okay
[Music]
all right
another message in the bottle wait how
does it flare go so far oh there it is
hey it's gone comforting let's do it oh
yeah clear it put it in the backpack we
are on a roll today well I get that
front end back you know double beam
action this pierce right through jeez
this is painful
yeah wait then we have to hold down ours
yeah yeah oh boy I don't know give to
point it out of her it won't let me like
move it that's the thing yeah I'll be
pushing in yeah oh there we go
she's in so much babe yelling like
[Music]
[Music]
talking about lots of things
you only think about yourself fine
it's try to help people stop saying it
don't ya those are some fightin words
whatever you look like a crab
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you know like she's personally attacking
me and doesn't know me at all my boat
can I go in the water free dive off is
our to the boat get a running start and
jump oh that was a graceful die oh I
love you bub you're gonna be both good
friend boat okay chapter you know we had
to deal with the troll troll always
saying mean things had to brighten up
their day right the final fight fire
with kindness wait what's the singing I
don't know it
kill them look find this area fight I
love you
[Laughter]
no okay no let's find another oh wait
okay let's go around it
wagon nice oh I agree
ringing around town
oh I think I have to go you know what
that like where was before with the
darkness and stuff here I can't go
through the gate yes
right I go to the scary area yeah I love
it
the scarier we conquered it with the
power of positivity talking okay oh here
we go
now we have to deal with our mixed
emotions
which I did not do to girl or look that
there as a child so or even now or last
week
okay okay here we go
yeah just have faith in ourselves as
bait then I guess kind of fishing yeah I
have a sexy hoo-ha oh okay how are we
supposed to make it over there they're
setting us up for failure serious up for
me to get eaten I get it I get it I get
it I get it like the sunshine swim fast
oh my god oh my god she's not the okie
the fun there's a little ledge there I
thought it was like all the way to the
wall a lot of yelling run
oh she scared me like I didn't know what
was happening but her he's flying
Harry bird and definitely not a seagull
monster yeah it seems familiar oh that
isn't exactly the first thing that I was
saying but still so far okay you can
write this wall here what's up Zelda
master we are doing very well today
playing some sea of Solitude just
hanging out having a good time whoa
and I trying to fight the darkness yeah
this is Kingdom Hearts
doesn't have those have to open Oh guess
my boat seemed to beat somehow yeah but
do I go we're getting close
I think I have to go in the water is it
any work oh man okay I think you're
pretty quiet so you might have like okay
there's a ladder over there to make that
only one oh yes let's just make our
lives more difficult
what's up kinetic sand or welcome to the
stream
shoot shoot okay Steven Seagal's 432 oh
snap so the boat kinetic says does
anyone have any theories on how the heck
this place got flooded
hmm I'm thinking it got flooded like you
know the theory is that everyone bow
alone and they turn into monsters right
so maybe it's all of our tears all of
our tears flooded the world you know cry
me a river
times a million through the gate into
the dark man Anthony Lake um I don't
think this thing's on switch
confirm that it's definitely on ps4 and
ru Xbox one maybe PC let me let me Oh
do you know her she's like you bright
and being ps4 Xbox one and PC her just
came out this past Friday
have you watched a new spider-man movie
asks currently yes but no spoilers
what's up I did enjoy it quite a bit yes
[Music]
before you look great just like
something by the classic oh man
this is scary oh boy young and can't do
my gosh
they're like replaying or traumatic
memories it's never written not good
well you know your brother Bill man and
everything will be even better this is
just setting us up to be even more
harrowing than I originally
Chloe we have a pet glowy oh you just
smack hey wait for me
he's like nah you just hit me with a
flare I'm searching for a girl in a
yellow coat plan you seen her I know I
know her very well not gonna believe
that
my oh my Oh
mining buckle says so what is this game
about I'm very interested so from what
we've seen so far so I can I can go onto
this ledge right I don't have that much
time coming back
my god that waves heading your way I
would I would go now what he's gonna
have to take some time to just turn
around oh he doesn't see you
we are pathetic okay whoo
[Laughter]
but yeah so this game so far it's about
you know dealing with darkness and
fighting it with the light but in terms
of a story key she's you know kind of
turned into a monster a little bit we're
trying to find this girl who seems to
have answers for us so yeah we're kind
of all learning but in the beginning
there was like a little disclaimer
saying it deals with mental awareness
and stuff like that so I actually really
it like that yeah it's just saying you
know this is about someone's personal
experiences in real life like how they
were dealing with stuff Bob Jim says
this is not a horror game well you could
have fooled us Jack beat who haha I have
to jump a good distance okay so it
doesn't go that far
so okay I get it I'm gonna I'll jump
once it's like over here right
in theory that works
oh wait it'll go that way I don't get it
okay and go go oh that was nicely time
because the way scaring the crap out of
me
oh my goodness okay I can't don't think
it's an electricity thing I think it's
like the darkness is shrouding us
kinetics and was asking my electricity
out growling stuff to you and I could
just hear it in the headphones like no
it's just like it gets so close to
beating you okay where is it now is this
thing
I'm not down to be okay we got another
little station and I know we have a
gradual oh we're just scoping out the
area fishy
mind your business oh my gosh oh my gosh
okay okay okay we're good rush me down
now okay
oh go oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh he couldn't fit
through he's a fatty get out of her oh
yeah there's a fatty fish can't make it
through the door
so far he's back yeah those lives
somewhere else this is a dangerous one
because I'm just oh now I'm here that's
a few times of screaming got it
this must be what a flying saucer is
hiding
I'll kill me not likely need me yeah
that's a 50-50 we were looking for I
think he's gonna kill us
she's such a sweetheart
that was that was chapter two that was
my chapter - hey mixed emotions was the
name okay now he's creepy he's like a
cat now you're creepy hello I'm Melissa
this is CSI hands just gave me the
heebie-jeebies that is weird
so I'm assuming we cannot go into the
water it's the three eye Raven those
were eight seven eight nine
like to go that way it's like right in
the middle of the water oh maybe I could
go on top of that but oh I do this gets
creepy it's like cool and creepy
hello hello you guys have heard me talk
about how I love ghost stuff all the
time but this is creepy Wow talking
trash oh I think I see some of you in
chat in this game right now staring at
us well they were like talking directly
to us they were like you both okay
glowy made a path thanks Chloe
thanks for keeping the hands away from
us I don't know like a flush out limbo
limbo is a really fun game to have you
tried limbo
Sorry Sorry
what's texting my boyfriend Oh young
adult kay is calling me I've gotta go
have fun with your friends yeah okay oh
no that was a little brother I remember
this place getting so sad okay we're
getting more on some real creepy level
things like how Chloe's just like make
them like follow you in the runner
I also don't have a health bar so I'm
not sure how much damage we are you
interesting so the flare isn't really
used for attacking right whereas that
boy should have started doing like dis
rap I'm like you don't like my singing
yeah all right so we have a jump we can
throw a flare that does nothing right
there we go yes my dude yes okay with
you just beat these boys up no I
wouldn't but I would get an adult figure
to help
oh nice Jukes Jukes you actually can't
aim the flare and the flare goes
naturally to the point that you want to
go to Storm Shadow this game is called
sea of solitude it's a new game from EA
like it's yes
Heather just told you they're not okay
why this one okay we're here look at him
look at him run stuck in please
boy I think it's like there we go yeah
that way oh yeah those a nice job that's
a lot oh hello there the corruption
oh you heard them whispering Orion Kelly
so creepy yeah he's running least scared
shook well you're in the light they
can't get you
I'm so upset that these guys are
bullying Sonny and I feel nothing to do
about it
it already happened I think that's the
worst part it's pretty cool leave me
alone
jump this is I mean I get one thing of
me check on myself
my brother I know right crime destroyed
all of them except one at least it gave
you a good check okay Paul so that's
where it's all seven killings but
activating the lakes does the trick well
that one guy was like
come here stop being so smart so yeah
guys what do you think of sea of
Solitude so far oh yeah it's too dark in
here glowy wait glowy wait no don't
leave
oh my gosh oh these kids are telling you
they're gonna go you know it's 2019
people file charges for things like that
nowadays
yeah I think those games really cool so
far
captivating it's trippy it's a little
scary okay we're out there you have
wavered when you have the little brother
[Music]
heartbroken they make you like - and
technically you I won't let you alone
again
cranky let me watch David Lynch or
Philemon night this okay know that I did
what are some of them I need to reach
sunny yeah I need to reach my car
I want hurry whatever she's like I'm so
over this oh man she's got the balance
of a god it was sad this smooth that was
this movie this game is taking me on a
roller coaster more heartbreaking than
our actual bhushan ryu cat says he chat
and gamespot so hasn't sunk in that in
six months we'll be in the future year
of 2020 it's pretty crazy I feel like
time has been going by so fast I
actually saw this really cool video
about the perception of time wolf also
that like you know when you're younger
you're like a year old your perception
of how long a year is it was literally
like your whole lifetime right so when
you're younger years and time feels like
it's a lot slower but then when you get
older you know like thirty years old
you've experienced 30 years so now it's
like really fast or it seems really
short I always thought that was like
super cool concept yeah the water lifted
you up we couldn't get a joke all right
[Music]
Jonathan said the weight of his tier
raised the sea level now that's deep for
real immense sadness
so it's true wait where are we just
talking about the theory of how the
place got flooded and I was like har har
use all of our tears oh my gosh if that
really but that was deadly again alright
here we go ready we got this yeah we're
prepared this time
don't really go that far
I've seen Drive oh wait
probably not the DRI appears to be
Mulholland Drive no no yeah it was like
who what she got to do go it doesn't go
that far
there will be no no eating here tonight
it's a far slim
[Music]
[Music]
can I go no see that's my mistake I
thought it went a lot farther
it doesn't really go that far
right so I would see I'm gonna need some
time to turn around because he's fat
like maybe when he's behind that other
platform because he has to go around the
platform
yeah the fish must have really gone
through something he didn't even know
his back hurt
well I went through it oh you should go
now I'm glad we have all of these
conveniently placed flat now you got it
you got it okay
please go again yeah
best
oh okay select the bottle on the way my
little bird I was like wait this isn't
working
apparently she's ditched all of us if
this game were available on Steam it is
available on PC and Xbox one and ps4 Jim
my brother it just came out on the fifth
this past Friday so ooh a chapter for it
don't give up on me oh you guys this
frickin game is like heart-wrenching
he's like flying towards your brother
yeah maybe all the seagulls are real
quick just gonna grab this this message
be careful of the water yeah so a lot of
those real leaders are all red like
things that interests me
here's some boy get over here brother
bro boy listen to me and your sister bro
remember me your sister I swear like oh
there's a hand here
oh he's on a stack you wait I just want
to help
please go bro bro go that's Fast and the
Furious oh yeah we need some nos on this
boat or something and get crow bro
sending us on these detours I'm not a
lolly it's welcome to though yeah
nevermind okay GUP turn okay so immense
sadness sadness
he's made far to make up
yeah I guess I get this time there's the
dock but if I don't want to leave oh
okay I got these hands are just creepy
yes it crisps nicely Park absolutely Oh
boat you need to keep them their hands
to themselves rude crow bro give me a
crab oh hi sure I actually didn't even
see it there until the prompt he does
want to be alone with his thoughts but
you know what I am II I am a that's the
first sign that he should be talking to
someone you learn to here first folks
I could have parked here the car boat no
I guess I should go get the boat yeah
there has to be another way around well
like what I went and I met up with him
this way
literally right there it's both yeah
instead of nos we can find old rockets
and just strap it to the back of the
boat sounds like a good plan Bhushan you
know guys I gotta go rescue my brother
all right I've gotta go synchro bro I
heard those guys would believe you let
me let me tell you a story about my boat
my marvelous
you can't keep lying well
no they won't because we'll protect you
we love you
we're gonna try this is really sad but
also a good lesson you guys even if
someone is running away pushing you away
that's when they need you the most so
yeah be a friend and love them I thought
he was warming up to us
wonder if we have to do something
specific when we get next maybe I can
get sure I buy but yeah this they're all
flying around him because he's their
friend we have to find all of them
before I use their crow Bros
hey I don't mean to say I'm on foot now
we're not in scary both oh man sunny
okay hurt you anymore was too loud I
want to help you okay feels bad no you
went for a swim
there's hands in there always swimming
oh so about it about run fast girl what
fast and uh never it is the perfect main
dish for Thanksgiving no is that it sir
brother we can't we cannot serve our
brother for dinner I can't but I can I
can boat I got to
go fast Bodhi let's go
he says that I brought my boat LOI leave
me to my brother take me to him now
oh we're lowering the sea levels well he
went into the water so this is a good
step in the right direction
hello bro bro maybe is not Crowborough
anymore me he's regular bro yeah maybe
he's hashtag cool girl like was you yeah
[Music]
but yeah for those are you just tuning
in we are playing some sea of Solitude
it's available on ps4 Xbox one and PC
right now because it was released this
past Friday it's been really pretty and
fun so far and also can I add on Chloe's
bag it's fine glowy love you
round two part hello Chloe Chloe is on a
mission
yeah Chloe is my brother your brother
Lee and the bird together equals Sonny
right all that's true it's like the
darkness side is girl the happy sine
wave bumpy one me so creepy okay alright
interesting oh no they're beating up
Chloe oh oh we gotta get rid of the
corruption
[Applause]
hello hurry up Sonny
you're going to be late for class what I
thought it was your favorite what's
wrong corruption what did he want to
tell me
his brother is everyone at the gym was
not high not again
fight back Chloe is Sonny okay so I have
to go to a bunch of different areas and
oh shoot shoot I think I could jump from
- places guys for those of you asking
how much the game is it is $19.99 on ps4
Xbox and PC which isn't bad because it's
really nice game I can do it I did it I
survived alright so I have to save for
Chloe buds and then the kids are feeding
up sunny right now no darn bullies any
glowy make me so upset
what's that sunny yeah we're gonna kill
you ha ha funny joke guys I mean I'll
know about you guys but I did get
bullied in school so this is like making
me so upset that they're beating up
glowy right now yes it was unfortunate I
actually went and graduated early so I
didn't have to deal with school anyway
Oh like thank you are you I'll beat your
Cobra or your C gal as someone said
earlier time to go it's them why don't I
remember this distracted
the punching sounds uh-oh it's up there
there's two more all right here we go
here we go I will save you Sonny we just
have to defeat the corruption in this
end I'm like a very sad no time left I
know I'm feeling like it's leading up to
that oh we're back hurts don't bake
anything are we
whoa all right or maybe it just looks
the same
yeah that part was okay and then the
last one I just want to be strong but
does he always be weak because oh my
gosh these bullies I hear talking we're
just talking trash about dad about him
we should told you that back then
and then like the dramatic piano music
ready
the violence
the emotional rollercoaster is that you
experience please baby of Solitude
I'm just made for this no whining they
say that - not whiney sometimes I feel
bad cake baby I'm sorry Sonny everything
you were saying but first look at this
my boyfriend text with me the funniest
thought picture ever come on I was just
a little distracted don't you think
these are funny you have no sense of
humor like me oh my God look I'm sorry
crying sneeze you were talking about her
friends right you had a great time with
them oh no she knows nothing
well then what's your problem tell me
[Music]
sunny sunny wait see you later I guess
oh my gosh oh my god sunny yeah you were
I was such an idiot oh my gosh you're
not alone anymore no she's still alive
and this isn't just like his soul that
dad flacco says this game is awkward
well you know sometimes facing some
roles like life issues can be a little
awkward sometimes but I think these
stupid kids men
all right spying bucko said his theory
is that sunny is dead oh my gosh but I
feel like he might be and I'm like oh
save sunny police you could do harder
being the worst sister EVER Oh oops
if she had a role this would be like
pretty cool yeah shoot a roll
okay great so spiny buckle says the
theory says sunny is said she blames
herself for his death and now she's
going through depression just like sunny
day that's like sounds super plausible
because that seems like the whole theory
here is like dealing with your
loneliness and your depression like
taking you to the darkness
metaphorically and actually I'm here to
help you oh man this shame is good I
know it's really sad but I think games
that you know put a light on this stuff
is good
[Music]
honey did they kill them no wouldn't
kill them oh there's so many of them and
the flu business oh I can get close to
it okay nice
oh my gosh no I push a girl it'll be
free oh my gosh
did we get really upset now oh gosh
there's so many of them okay it's okay
boss fight
it's like messed up cuz you can't even
effective best now well maybe he's just
watch out get your stupid bully face out
of the way call CPS geez crime if only
that was an option in this game
we have to call all of these bullies
Caryn's that's what we need to do is our
weird line to us
[Music]
yeah or at least done then I think I
have to get push
we want you to suffer a little bit at
least oh whoa whoa oh you're about to
get hit with combos here oh just in time
he freed about everything we did oh my
got the chills
Jonathan says maybe sunny as her split
personality we were thinking it was
glowy was Sunny's split personality not
your friends
nice he obliterated them this is a step
in the right direction I'm so sorry I
didn't see any of this before I'm so
sorry I didn't listen to you I've never
been I promise
so I feel like yeah I know I'm like we
must know got some happy music uh-oh
something's I know right this is a lot
is he gonna turn back into a normal boy
is he she's smiling so yes big old tears
[Music]
she's feeling in her own darkness still
though
and you know talked a lot about her
boyfriend but we're not so sure she
still has that boyfriend if she is in
this state of being a big boat oh snap
upgrade
okay so it's the goal here to let go
save all your people who are in this
world that's we take crow bro I think
yeah this is like home base I think you
can climb up you okay honey
Oh what what I can't
he's going back two non-monster worlds
probably always sunny come back well no
you're so far yeah strange the first
monster
she said such terrible things about me
oh no don't keep shower than that I only
cared about myself I didn't say before
see that's also kind of toxic though did
a girl again it feels like a lifetime
since I met her whoever she was looking
for I hope she found him yeah he's
bailing
real fast I know like our screens
getting all miss you in again
well I don't know how to get back we're
not supposed to miss huan'er string
beretta is at the sky so yeah I think
it's like different worlds yeah we're
gonna have to like save someone okay
Sonny we just gave you this boat okay
there's gotta be someone who can help us
I'll have a look around don't think so
you gotta go look for help because Sonny
done crashed boys only boat can't get on
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay whatever
sunny have keep your boat that's fine
all right someone help oh I see
ready okay this is where we were
I used to get into temptation
Oh oh boy it's getting really deep now
hello I'm not sure if that guy can help
but I guess we're gonna ask anyways
right where did girl go I've completely
forgot about was it her oh that is her
that's a buoy so oh this is a big guy
big girl okay we found her there you are
thank goodness you're okay angler fish
she can understand her and she looks
normal but he can't understand her
brother
me
everyone one is something I have no time
for other people's problems
now where was John enough if you want
he'll go to him
these payments is getting heavier earth
heavier weightlifting champion is the
ethology it you see where to go for such
weight she was just here oh no no no no
look what Jack gave me this is de banda
was telling you about it's genuine
[Music]
definitely her mom
wowie what sunny you want to kiss to
wait your mom and the chameleon yep
and mom whose monster fish though this
whole trip was this idea no I know I'm
surprised I mean
[Music]
around the tentacle as the boxer
out having a soy
well I guess I'm gonna die
whoa
he was creepin
for even this game is heavy
it was very happy Tuesday everybody yeah
yeah happy to
[Music]
it's really good so far though I hear
him growling oh I saw my mom stir dating
crime is killing it with the puns today
no okay
I've got no plan
oh god no okay here we go here we go all
right go for it
okay so
[Music]
if he's not looking in your direction he
doesn't immediately start running before
you swimming to you whatever let's see
go now yeah oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god
hello
[Music]
is my point oh there it is select oh he
can't get on this roof on this
underwater roof
I don't care distant lately
okay biggest drag is heavily brand used
to used to be the most loving man on the
planet but now he
[Music]
sorry yes I had a feeling
the boyfriend was going to come into
play at some point so there's a Ledge
everything
but there's also a fish
Chloe
that way okay man looking out over there
fast looks like I'm not sure if he can
get you once it rises like that but he
gets close okay hello where are you
going
why is he working again what I don't
know okay why does he never do things
with us anymore oh gosh this is like so
sad okay so we've got three minutes left
of the stream okay so all the boyfriends
Jonathan says plot twist her boyfriend
is the psycho fish trying to eat you
that sounds really accurate
on to the fin yeah that sounds right
okay go girl I need you to run for me
[Music]
it's all squishy Zahn Chapter six
actually we made it to chapter six I
think we're gonna go ahead and wrap it
up right about there before we get too
far into the story I mean we actually
got through quite a bit of it was that
wasn't I feel like we were barely even
scratching the surface
oh I hope everyone has a really great
day in lunch I know that Gabe's heavy
it's a little sad and we can all kind of
confirm that the brother did not die yes
I am actually very handy about that
that's a win because that would have
been that would have been we saved him
yeah we did it so didn't years later
after all of the abuse that happened we
did it though exactly like this game is
crazy I think it's like you know giving
some importance to like mental health
and stuff like that and little things
and how easily we can get caught up but
hey just keep on reaching out to your
friends and you know talk to people you
love I know life gets busy but sometimes
just checking in and talking or you know
offering an ear even if someone doesn't
want to talk I think is really important
too I know I'm getting all getting all
emotional here but I don't know I think
it's really important yeah so check this
game on you guys see you solitude just
came out this Friday it's on Xbox ps4
and PC and that is gonna wrap up the
show for us today so we will catch you
guys next time
have a good day seriously yeah
you